Hey, what's going on? It's bill bird.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and ah,
just check in.
Hey,
what's going on? How's your
week going? Is it going good?
That is good. You keeping your
head above the fucking water.
Um, I'm having, it's a great way.
I'm having the best of times.
I'm having the worst of times.
My fucking phone, my phone.
I don't know what's going on with it.
Nothing on it says it needs to be updated,
but it keeps saying that it needs to be
updated and now it won't connect to my,
my wireless cell phone carrier.
Sometimes it does.
Sometimes it doesn't have. I'll look
at it. Oh, what is it doing now?
What is it doing now?
I can't tell if I fucking fixed it or not.
You know what? These fucking assholes
at apple do these fucking assholes.
Do you remember back in the day you could
opt out and not update your phone and
you could keep it forever. So
they're like, oh God forbid God.
God's a did one fucking nickel.
Those cheap fucking money grubbing
corporate cons. God for fucking bid.
One fucking nickel rolls out the
window that they feel belongs,
rightfully belongs in their pocket.
So now where do they do now?
You can't opt out of the update.
Now you have to update the phone and it's
all designed to fill up your old phone,
right? So then you fucking
bring the fucking thing in
and then you've got to get
the one that like take,
takes a picture of your face or
whatever it does. And then now,
now we'll take your
old phone and two what?
Okay,
give it to the poor bastard
and Philippines that had
to fucking put the thing
together.
Here's your reward.
Okay?
For working in our fucking factory
for 20 fucking hours a day,
making these new iPhone 19 so we're
going to give you the old iPhone seven
way to go there, buddy. You know,
and then, and if you don't do that,
he just fucking throw the things out
and they end up in the fucking ocean.
And like somehow these people
aren't the fucking problem.
These people are let, let's go to
the other fucking side of the world.
Blow $1 billion a fucking month fight
and 3,500 jerk offs on a fucking jungle
gym.
But these cunts who are polluting the
ocean have poisoned the fucking food
supply.
Turned it into God knows what.
You got nine year olds walking around
with fucking mustaches cause there's so
much fucking human growth hormone or
whatever the fuck they're putting in the
God damn shit,
right that they're not the problem.
Really.
That's all fucking isis has to do.
Just spend 300 grand on a
fucking chicken Parmesan plate.
Okay.
Help finance your fucking campaign.
Then they're in the clear.
That's all they need to do.
Sorry.
That's how far I take it with a
fucking update on my phone. Hey Bill,
why don't you just give in man,
everybody's going to do it, man.
Go get the fucking phone with you.
You have your face recognition.
I've been playing like this.
Mental tennis,
I keep threatening to leave
apple like fuck these guys.
Cause my laptop's almost
full. My, uh, my cell phone.
I don't know what's going on with it.
It seems to be working when I'm
around my house. But it's hilarious,
right when I need the fucking thing,
it shuts off,
which makes me feel like the computer
can't in it is looking at my calendar. Oh,
he needs, he needs to do a radio tour.
You know the phones just like God,
I think we'll just shut down now.
Last night I had to call in the fucking
sports gambling podcast with Shawn Green
and Ryan.
Yeah.
All right. Which Selby be
playing on this show tonight?
Actually, no, I'm sorry.
I'll be playing it later on on
my podcast right before the,
the throwback episode would be playing
and after I'm done ranting about my
fucking phone,
um,
you know, I'm actually
considering leaving, but then,
you know, somebody said,
well apple actually pushed back against
the FBI, you know, on the privacy thing.
And it's just like, what?
Then they're also doing all
this fucking creepy shit. I,
you know, the worst fucking move I
ever made was getting a smartphone.
Yeah.
All right.
I should have stayed with the flip phone,
but now I got the smart
phone and you know,
it's like you're riding first class
and now you have to go back to coach.
But I'm really considering considering,
you know,
maybe I'll get like a second phone for
all these fucking radio tour things that
I have to do that I love doing.
Calling in all these great shows
that had helped me promote my shows.
Maybe I'll just do that because I'd never
heard of anybody talking about their
day of flip phone. Fucking crapping out.
Really. Does that make me a hipster?
If I get one of those?
Um, I dunno. You know,
God damn well it'd be
down the apple store.
Here's the iPhone 10 show
us your face. Oh, okay.
I'm trusting you won't do
anything elicit with that.
Everything's above board even though
you're not concerned with polluting the
fucking environment. I mean, to be honest
with you, liked with these corporations,
like when, when, when does it
fucking stop these fucking bankers?
When does it fucking stop?
It's unreal and you can't say anything.
You fucking say anything.
They label you a socialist.
It's like I'm not the one polluting the
fucking oceans. I'm fine with this phone.
How much better does
the camera have to be?
Do going to be able to count the pores
on my fucking relatives faces. It's fine.
You did a bang up job.
How about this?
How about you all on the phone
and I'll fucking rented from you
Eric and much more forward.
Okay.
Everyday Marsh Baylor,
they better,
someone shows up to work.
They have the better phone.
It makes the others less than.
Um,
anyways, so that I got, I got rid of the
worst part of week, which is that shit.
And of course I have to
fly out early tomorrow morning to go
to Saginaw, Michigan, which by the way,
I just found out from some
of my relatives that uh,
my great grandparents had a house
out there like a hundred years ago.
So I have the address. No,
I won't be saying it. Yes,
I put it in my phone.
Yes.
Steve jobs from beyond the
grave is already fucking
in a fucking drone with his
spirit hovering over it so
it can capture me there.
Do some fucking face recognition about
the top of my head, whatever the,
whatever the fuck those creeps
are trying to do over there.
Like some of these people,
they literally have to put nets outside
their factory to prevent people from
leaping to their fucking deaths.
And for some reason they're not a problem.
Yeah.
It's not a fucking problem.
Look, the other fucking way.
I don't, I don't get it. Um,
okay.
Um, anyways, plowing ahead. So
I'll be in Saginaw, Michigan,
which I've never performed there,
so I'm very excited.
Okay.
MMM.
To go there. Uh, my hour,
I got an hour and a half right now and
it is more than ready to be recorded.
So freckles got to figure it out when
he's going to do as next special cause.
Last night I did a private Gig,
um,
for this Jewish Kimmy odd and um,
bye. It's such a great time. I was
only supposed to do a half hour.
I felt like I was on stage for 20 minutes
and I looked down and I had done an
hour. And so then the psych, all this
is a, it's time. It's time to go.
But I had such a good time at
that fucking Gig, you know,
usually I don't like to perform in front
of like all like one group of people,
you know.
Okay.
Cause everybody has the same perspective
and then it kind of closes down what
you can talk about. Um, but
this crowd last night was day,
what day were raw. They were,
they were amazing, you know,
as buddy of mine book the thing.
Okay.
And uh, we were backstage and he had
cigars and shit. It was just like my,
one of my favorite gigs of the year.
And um,
I gotta be honest with you,
like I've, I've really fucking,
I'm learning how not to get in
arguments with people, you know,
cause we were just talking about
all this shit and then he brings up,
what do you think about Israel?
I'm like, oh, I could suck, dude.
I'm not going to fucking
get into this with you.
What I think about it, I've been
waiting. What the, what do you want foot?
It's like everything, it starts
with a good idea. How it's executed.
Is that the best idea?
I don't, I don't know.
I think there's mistakes Beta both sides.
And then it's literally like trying to
talk to a sports fan where they can't see
anything that their team does rug.
So he started to get into it and
I was just like, you know what?
Fair enough. What do you think
about the red sox Astros?
Like I'm not going to get into this
fucking debate with you. You know?
Um,
okay.
And we avoided this huge fucking
debate on something that I have.
I'm not really well read on,
but the old me,
I would dove right in both fucking feet,
you know what I mean?
Comparing this country
with the native Americans,
I was prepared to do all of that,
none of which I'm well read on.
And I was just like,
you know what pill?
Why don't you just shut the fuck up
and smoke your cigar? So I just said,
you know,
it's fair enough.
Why am I going to get this guy all stirred
up speaking in third of a fact that I
overheard and a fucking airport and I
let it go. And it was great. You know,
he's another great part of my week.
The fucking Red Sox beat the New York
Yankees and another playoff series that's
two in a row. You know, we're on a hell
of a run. I think they beat us like, well,
I guess not the place, but you
know what I mean? They beat us up.
I think this is our century.
MMM.
All right, here's the deal. You know, but
you know me, I don't fucking rub it in.
All right.
I want to congratulate the Yankees on a,
on a hundred win season and the
direction that they are going in,
because those guys, they're going to
be a force and as much for Yankee fans,
as much as this one hurt,
um,
it's going to make like
those your team feeling,
that feeling of fucking losing, they're
not going to want to feel it again.
And I already thought that they
were, they were playing great. Um,
and I'm not going to sit there and act
like I'm a GM and I know what PC you need.
Uh, oh, now what to say. Now look at Lulu.
My fucking now my computer one fucking
start back up. All right, here we go. Um,
but uh,
it was just a great series and um,
you know,
I dunno,
it's just great for baseball when
those two teams come together and uh,
yeah.
Yeah. And I realized when I was watching
it that I don't hate the Yankees.
I mean it, how can you hate the greatest
fucking organization, 27 championships?
You can't get mad at that. You know
what? And I don't even hate their fans.
It's just that small segment
of fan that if they won,
you know,
the amount of shit that they would've
talked would have been just like, um,
like to just see like
in the eighth inning,
right when we loaded up the basis in the
clincher and that stud came out for the
Yankees and he just pitched him out
of the situation or whatever the,
or a lot of the situation put himself in.
I can't even remember.
It was a fucking blur.
And when he struck out that
dude with the bases loaded,
when he went to the Dugout,
those two fat fucks like
ringing up the last batter act.
Like those are the morons.
They're like, oh dope
Jay,
those fucking mouth breathing morons.
Those are the ones straight across the
board in sports that patriots have those
fans, red sox have, you know,
I'm not saying all of their fans,
they just have those fucking
people and they're the ones that,
um,
they're the ones that ruin it.
Okay.
You know,
like Dale,
those are the ones that like if I
actually sat across from him when they got
over the fact that I was a red sox
fan and I wanted to talk the rivalry,
I could never get past.
Yeah. Bogo, Babe Ruth though, Joe,
like those people, it's
just like, all right.
So that was the only time I felt
hate in that series. What is,
when I saw those fucking idiots, and
I gotta be honest with you, dude.
Uh, this is embarrassing to say,
but the level of mouth breather,
yeah.
When they painted the crowd in Yankee
Stadium and at Fenway Park is just
unparalleled.
It's in Philly too.
I don't know what it is.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
It goes down south. They've
got the southern bell yet
the fuck and go to old boy.
You go out and Midwest, you get those
people dress like Pete Carroll. You know,
just like how does a person
in their 20s dress like that?
Then you go out to the west coast,
they got their own vibe, you know?
Yeah.
And but like I'm telling the east coast
like I gotta I gotta be honest with you
like we do,
we have corner.
It's so weird cause you have some of
the smartest fucking people like Boston,
New York have a real similarity
there where both cities,
okay,
uh,
re really ride on the coattails of the
amount of smart people that move to the
city. You know, Boston
has, they have Harvard,
they got fucking Mit, they
got bu, Emerson College,
all these places where all these smart,
talented kids come into this
city juxtaposed to the locals
and New York.
You got all that bridge and tunnel,
all these fucking people
that move into Manhattan.
Okay.
You know, and really make it
what it is. And then he's dead,
dead. Duh. Oh,
these fucking morons sweatpants,
Hoodie,
fucking tad stake eat and fucking
mouth breathing mouth breathing fucking
morons.
Um,
I got a kick out of that and I am one
of those fucking morons by the way.
I'm not,
I'm not trying to be a goddamn elitist
tier now that it moved out the fucking
phony ass Hollywood. I'm not looking
down my adorable little knows that yet.
No,
I am not.
Okay.
I was that guy.
I was a guy out the fucking outfield
who wanted to make his section laugh,
who was loud fucking drunk.
I did that. Plenty of games.
Okay.
It's gotta be some sort of security
footage out there of it. Um, anyways,
so sale comes in the eighth
inning and just, I mean,
okay,
for a red sox fan versus the Yankees,
I mean,
I don't think you ever get over fucking
2003 the seventh and eighth fucking
innings in and then it's just
like those innings, you know,
all the way back to Bucky
makes you fucking nervous and
he fucking just cruise right through
the eighth inning. I'm like, Oh my God,
we have a three run fucking lead.
And then I see Kimbro up and I'm
just like, don't put that guy in.
Yeah.
How about the fucking guy in the seventh
inning with the Bob Stanley Torso?
I don't know anybody's fucking
names anymore. I got a kid,
I don't have time to figure this
shit out. I was going like, oh,
this mother fucker, look at this.
How is he this out of shape?
Okay.
With all the, all the exercise videos
out there, all the fucking nutritionist.
I'll look at this guy.
Look at this guy.
He should have that fucking cop utility
belt on when he's out there pitching.
So anyways,
he does great fucking sales.
Shuts them down.
Then Kimbro comes out and what he
proceeds to load the fucking basis.
And I'm telling you,
I thought I was past it.
I kept telling him all I wanted to see
him do was when at once they've won it
three times coming down from three,
three Oh you know,
all three till till when
you know,
biggest comeback in baseball
history. I'm good. I,
I really thought that. I
believe that. And then I just,
the night that he came and I
could not stay in the room,
I want to apologize
to Kimbro for all the shit I
said about him in that antique.
Oh God.
I was out in the kitchen between pitches
and I would run and I poked my head in
another ball and then I would just
Tourette's walking out and my daughter was
asleep. So I'm like whispering,
she's just fucking pushed off.
Fucking strike your fucking cards.
Right? You fucking red bearded fucking,
what the fuck would Julie
fucking sale in there?
Yeah.
So anyways,
when that's they,
then it's 42 then it's fucking 40 the,
it's a fucking batter to make it 42 hits,
a batter with the bases loaded,
walks in a fucking run basically,
or whatever.
He hits a bad run in Dennis sac fly.
Now it's four to fucking three.
Those fat mouth breathers, I can see a
fucking freaking out the jelly bodies.
And then there's a slow dribbler
down to the third base line.
And I'm like, oh my God, this
is going to be an infield hit.
And then he calls the fucking dude
out and I did the most embarrassing
celebration dance.
And then they're like,
it's under review. And I'm like,
oh my God, it's this game tied.
Are they going to tell me that this
fucking game is tied? And then they,
of course they came back and said
that it wasn't, but Jesus Christ,
I can't believe how much I still care.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So then I texted a buddy of mine from
back in the day and I was just like,
did you ever think you'd see the red sox
drink champagne in the fucking Yankee
stadiums? You twice in your
life. This is unbelievable.
And then he wrote back to me,
it's dead, it's really dead.
All that fucking Bucky dent shit is dead.
And I laugh and I was like,
yeah,
but guys like you and me are
still going to have, you know,
post traumatic stress disorder from
all of those times where it wasn't.
And he was like laughing going, yeah. So
I think there's like this weird sort of,
um,
it's schism the word between
red sox fans right now.
There's the people that lived through it
and the people that don't know anything
but what's going on right now.
And I like being around those people.
The second ones,
the ones who are just thinking positive,
cause I actually found
myself saying positive shit.
He's going to strike this bomb out. Come
on now. Go ahead. Break their hearts.
They're all fucking cheering.
I remember when Yankee Stadium
used to get really loud,
I would get all fucking nervous going
out. God, they just gonna Willem in there.
What's fucking GED they're going
to do, you know? Um, so anyways,
I can't believe that we want it.
And I really thought that we
were going to lose that series.
And I also feel that if we fucking blue,
if we blew game four,
I didn't see us coming back when
a game five. Um, I just didn't.
So now we're under the fucking Houston
Astros who nobody is talking about for
whatever God damn reason went through
the Indians like a buzz saw and scary
Terry Francona.
Um,
I dunno, tell today and all of these
fucking guys, these guys are like,
these guys had dialed in.
So we will see how we do when
we need fucking price to,
uh,
to finally get a victory.
I know a lot of you guys do what's with
this we stuff, I hate people who say,
wait, well I'll tell you why I say we
because people go, if you say we won,
they're like, oh, you didn't win. But
if you fucking lose, it's like, yeah,
you guys suck. You know, you guys
fucking suck. You guys choked.
You guys fucking blew it. Right? But
then all of a sudden you win. If he say,
if you use the Pronoun we right,
can you still use that Pronoun by the way?
Or did somebody who wants to fucking had
the balls put on their knee and their
Dick on their ear?
Fucking we who's we?
Uh, me, my Dick and my balls. I'm sorry.
Anyways, plowing ahead. So like
I mentioned, I'm in Saginaw,
Michigan and this is all leading up
to uh,
my last big shows of the year.
November 7th,
I am going to be at Madison Square Garden.
I am going to be recording that night,
hopefully successfully this time to
put out a god damn album last time.
As you remember,
I had the set of my life and they didn't
understand what I was trying to do and
they only took the sound from the board.
So it was just me really
loud on my microphone.
Sounding ridiculously excited in front of
about eight people. Um,
so I'm going to try,
I'm going to try to fucking do that again.
And then after that I have three nights
at the unbelievable Chicago theater,
arguably the greatest marquis.
I think it's the greatest marquis
and a all this show business. Um,
and with that I would read
some advertising. There we
go. Um, oh look who's here.
I all me go. Oh, Amigo. Oh me.
Oh my go.
I'm never going to know how to say this.
A revolutionary toilet seat replacement.
Are you anal about
cleanliness in the bathroom?
What if I told you I could change
the way you poop? Jesus Christ.
Um,
have you ever really thought about poop?
That just sounds like a wet one coming
right out of your ass. You know,
it sounds like the noise it makes.
Have you ever really thought
about wiping with toilet paper?
Like really thought about it?
I'll give you a chance right now.
Motivate your audience. Talk about
your experience with all me. Go.
Oh my go. Ah, I haven't used it
yet. It sounds like the poor man's,
but a choose one to two copy points
to rotate and your spot, all right,
washes you and all the right places.
You know, you take it a shit.
You can wipe your ass cheek all you want,
but that's not going to fix the problem.
Uh,
that cadets what they're
doing in Washington. Um,
that would be my campaign slogan.
I think it's time.
This country stop wiping their ass cheeks
and I got down to business with this
all. I liked this guy. He makes sense.
He talks like me adjust the
water temperature position,
pressure with movement. Feels
like you just took a shower.
I got to tell you some,
I've used a bad day before. It was fuck
made me laugh my ass off, no pun intended,
but I cannot even begin to tell you the
fresh feeling I fed afterwards, you know.
Anyways, it feels like you just took
a shower. It features a heated seat,
a nightlife, soft closing, air dry,
remote controlled deodorize
carbon filter eliminates odors.
Say Goodbye to toilet paper, save
trees, water and electricity.
US alone uses 36 million rolls
of toilet paper in one day.
It's quick and easy. I've come around
to these guys, you know what I mean?
Cause I know that that thing uses a
bunch of energy with the electricity.
And all of that type of shit.
But you know,
this is not a bunch of
paper going into the water.
Police says no separating that you
have to do down at the fucking Mil.
Whatever the hell they do anyways. Plus
you can install it and just 20 minutes.
Okay,
20 minutes. Well, if you just
have an analog toilet seat,
I mean you can put it in about fucking
two minutes, but we'll it wash your ass.
You know, you can't have your cake and eat
it. People, uh, do your business at Omi.
Go. Oh, Amigo. Oh my. Go, uh,
get $100 off on your order
when you go to m y o m I.
G. O d o t c o m. Slash
B u. R. R. That's Omi.
Go. Oh my go. Oh, am I a g o go
to all me, me, me, me, me, me.
Go. Dot Com slash Berg get a hundred
dollars off. The future's weird at first.
Let it be weird. Ooh, got a little
creepy there in the end. All right.
Legal Zoom, legal, zoom. Uh,
you know the saying time is money.
It's true.
Especially when you run your own business.
But running a successful business
involves taxes, contracts,
and a whole lot of fine print things
that eat up too much of your time. Well,
it's time to turn to legal zoom.
Over the last 17 years,
more than a million Americans have
used legal zoom to help launch their
businesses. This is is, but
that's not the only thing.
Legal Zoom also has a network
of independent attorneys
and tax professionals who
can provide you with the advice you
need to get through the daily grind of
running your business.
And the best part is you don't have to
worry about driving to anyone's office or
being billed by the hour. Uh,
since legal zoom is not a law firm,
you can count on legal zoom to provide
the business resources you need and
services that fits your schedule services.
Wait,
invest your time and your money into
your growing business and let legal zoom
help with the legit stuff.
Go to legal zoom.com now,
capital letters and use code burpee. You
are are at checkout for special savings.
Once again, that's Promo Code
[inaudible] at legal zoom,
legal zoom where life meets
legal. Oh, last but not least. Oh,
I like these guys. Butcher
box, butcher blocks,
dude.
Um,
butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass
fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage, bread, pork.
The greatest fucking meat I've
ever tasted in my life in my house.
I felt like a five star chef for those
of you don't know what heritage bread,
pork is that, that,
that is uh, that is, um,
pure bred pigs that they can trace
their bloodline back to Europe.
All right. This is, this
is like, I can't tell you.
I'm going to just kind
of compare it to fuck,
I can't do that because then
they're going to be like,
can you please not compare us to the clan?
Um,
yeah.
If you want to get racist with your pork
or it'd be a little nice if you want to
go Westminster with your pork.
That's I'm telling you, dude,
you fucking make to sear it on both sides.
Finish it in the oven in a skillet.
You bring it back out, a little rosemary
butter bath. Oh, if I get about it.
Unbelievable.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meat starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they kill them.
Each box comes with at least
nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
Unless you're a gluttonous
fat fuck, you'll probably
blow through it in two days.
You can choose from five different box
types. All beef, beef and chicken. Ooh,
beef and pork mixed box.
We are the world custom box
lets you choose your own cuts.
Antibiotic Hormone Free
Butcher box believes in health,
a healthier food system.
Good for them.
Where everyone has access to
meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics,
free of hormones,
and humanely raised on an open
pasture before they murder them.
Okay.
Selection,
butcher block.
Carefully cure rates to find a selections
and cuts and makes it a breeze.
To customize your own delivery,
build your own box to get exactly
what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with
the customizable subscription. Uh,
recipes are available on
butcher box websites and
videos are available to the to
follow along on butcher
box youtube channel.
I already gave my personal experience for
Free Bacon and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com and
enter Promo code bird.
That's $20 off and Free Bacon
Promo Code [inaudible] all right.
You know something.
You know what the one that when Peta
always shows those things about animals,
you don't want that really
fucking got me the other day,
I can't remember if I mentioned
this on the Monday morning podcast.
I was driving down to this
gig in Bridgeport and right
next to the place that I
was playing,
they had this sign would that showed a
cow and then it's calf and the calf was
like touching face with its with
its mother. You know what I mean?
Like this beautiful, you know,
mother kid fucking type of vibe.
And it said,
this is this caps first day
and last day with his mother.
Okay,
please stop drinking milk.
And I was like Jesus Christ.
You know, now I'm separating
families. You know,
I don't know. I don't know what's going
on with the fucking world right now, but I
good, uh, um, starting with
the end and the mirror.
MMM.
I'm asking him to change his freckles.
Those were the original lyrics. I actually
wrote that and I sent it to Michael.
He's like, well, it seems a little
ginger specific. And I said, mark,
don't go southward around me
or I'll do something offensive to your
race if I could figure out what the fuck
it is.
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
I am, I'm working on
my temper. I am, I am,
I'm not going to get into arguments
about people with their fucking belief
system. I would like to fucking, you know,
I'm not saying I'm going to
become vegetarian, but like,
I would like to really continue to promote
more companies that at least they're
saying that doing this, I hope
they're not fucking lion. And, uh,
I gotta be honest with you, man, I've
switched over to fucking almond milk.
But it's the thing about Omelets,
they take up so much goddamn water grow
and then, you know, there's
just too many fucking people.
Okay.
It always comes down to that.
How do we live on this planet?
We need to get the fucking
population Dowd right?
That's what we need to do.
Okay.
We need to stop fighting
about the goop in the ground.
We just stop fucking screaming and
yelling at each other. We got it.
It's like we have an a tug of war
when we should just fucking, I dunno,
you can't do it.
How do you get on the same page?
How do you get everybody to start
pulling in the same fucking direction?
Yeah.
Do you know like when they take a black
light and they go through like a fucking
hotel room to see where
all the fucking Jesus,
if they could come up with one of those
lights for sociopath's and I don't know
what you would do with those people.
I mean,
I think you gotta take 'em out and you
certainly can't stick them on an island
and have all of those fucking
lunatics there at the same time.
There's another great Scifi movie.
Somebody invents a Tj's
light for fucking sociopaths.
They weed them all out,
but this, but they're,
they're big flaw in their
system is their fucking liberal.
So they can't flip the switch
and electrocute him and
they stick them all on the
same island and then they just
create a master race of sociopaths.
And then there's this warlike psychotic
fucking people and then they get in
their God viking ships and they start
coming over to everybody else walking
around with their Beta energy
in their Birkenstocks stocks.
All right.
And of course there's
one good one over there.
I Dunno why some of this some sort of
fucking lefty gene. It's, it's Hollywood.
It's going to have to be the lefties
save and the fucking day, right? Um,
he gets over there and he warns him and
he has to teach all of these fucking
Bergen stocked fucking leftys how to
fight fire with fire and become warlike.
All right.
It's basically empire strikes
back meets police academy.
That's how I would pitch it.
All right.
With a sprinkle of the Dave Matthews band.
All right. That's your dumps.
Scifi movie of the week. Um,
all right. Now as a red
sox fan. I have one more.
I got to tip my cap one more time out.
Up on a percent respect for the
Yankees in their organization.
Do you realize that if the New York
Yankees do not win the world series next
year,
this will only be the second
decade since the 1920s that they,
that they didn't win a world series.
Do you want to stand? Let's, let's,
let's fucking look this up
here for a second. All right.
If you want to get jealous
as a fucking sports fan.
New York. Yeah. Keys. Don't you?
Was He fucking sang about New Jersey?
Frank? Just as a fuck you to New York.
That never thought he was good
enough until he was good enough.
Then they took him in and
sat around. Um, you know,
I wanna wake up and as city
that fucking rakes, right?
He's singing about Newark
and Phi Dom Bridge and tunnel
to noon. I will sleep. Sorry.
It had to rhyme. All right.
New York Yankee. Where the
fuck, let me hit pause.
So this doesn't take forever. All right.
Only had to put a pause for two seconds.
All right.
The 1920s all right.
1919 they get babe Ruth. Okay.
The 1920s they won three titles.
19 231927192080 here come the
1930s they one night they won one,
two,
three four five 1930 to 1936
93719381939 including four in a row.
They want to half the fucking
world series in that decade.
1940s they won one,
two,
three four.
They had an off decade.
They only won four 1940 94319471949 and
then here come the 1950s where they won
one, two, three four, five,
six including five in a row.
If you count 1949 cause they already won
1949 then they won 95019511950 to 1953
then they won 1956 and 1958 by the way,
honorable mention to the Cleveland
Indians when they won in 1946 I believe,
or was it 48 I can't remember.
48 I think. All right.
Then the 1960s they want to 1961 1962
then the 70s they want to 1977 1978 now
granted now this is like fucking,
you know,
25 30 teams in the league and they're
still winning the eighties they don't win
any.
I'm certainly one twenties thirties
forties fifties sixties 76 fucking decades
in a row.
2000 they come right back and they went
390690890 nine to 2000 they when they
won in 2000 2009 they want to,
how do you count the decades by the way?
You count it from sometimes.
Is it 81 to 90 I don't know. I,
when the odometer flips, that's
how I count it. All right?
So they have yet to win one this decade.
So they've basically,
one of the last nine decades
they won a championship,
like a drought for them is
not winning in a decade.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It really is ridiculous.
And they have more titles than the
Celtics. More titles, the Lakers,
more titles than the fucking,
okay.
Montreal Canadians.
More titles than the fucking Green Bay
packers with all of their Superbowls in
all of their fucking super bowl titles
and the Pittsburgh Steelers Superbowls
thrown in. So there you go. And,
and I think that they're going to win
one here in the next couple of years,
the direction that they're going. So, uh,
I'm very happy that we were able
to beat them. And like I said,
I don't fucking rub it in and got nothing
but respect from, that's the podcast.
Be sure to listen now to do my,
my fucking picks,
my NFL picks for the week.
Okay.
Which, uh, you know, I barely, you know,
I don't have time to pay it to. I should,
I really should start playing fantasy
football so I know who some of the fucking
people are in the league.
Um,
so I'm on the show in green and Ryan
Cramer's show the sports gambling podcast.
Um, and that's it. Other than that,
after that we'll have a little bit of
music and then a throwback from a podcast
from a Thursday gone by earlier this
year or God knows when. All right.
Dad said go red sox. Uh, Eh, uh,
go pats and all of this stupid
mouth breathing shit that I watch.
Okay.
We,
wow.
We
got to be one
that
bill
we're on. The sports gaming podcast
is brought to you by my book.
He died a g my book.
He is the leader in online sports books.
You use the Promo Code Bill bets for
a 100% deposit bonus play when and get
paid. And My bookie. Dot. Agee joining
us on the line bill burr. Bill.
Your red socks just defeated the
Yankees in the alds three to one. How,
how excited are you for them to move on?
I can't believe how much I still care.
I was trying to lie to him cause
I didn't, I don't feel, you know,
the rent price was touching.
I was like you need a one tune and all
the great teams like the Yankees out and
I was just,
you know,
all I wanted to see him was when at
once the movie was over roll credits.
I mean what are they going
to do a chance in 2013 at me?
I said all of that stuff.
I couldn't believe
how much you know what it is.
It's not the Iq score
and it's not the work.
It's their fans.
It's what really it is
not even all of their fans.
It's those mouth breathers and
morons that those whack-a-mole fans,
you know the guys who like got down when
they lose and then pop their head up
when they,
when I literally have a friend,
I'm not going to sign up front and
got a coworker, another comedian.
I didn't hear from that guy since gained
three to 2014 and 2004 I didn't hear
from him again until the red sox blew
that meet with Bobby Valentine and
September in 2012 like nine years later
he popped his head up to start talking
trash. The next year we won the world
series. I haven't heard from him again.
I guarantee you if the Yankees won this
thing that I would have heard from.
That's the only time I hear from this
guy is when the Yankees beat the red sox.
Well yeah,
why not?
I mean I do agree there was a great shot
during the game last night where they
had this trio of like just
straight from the Bronx,
like slightly struck that guy out.
They honestly they make me,
I mean as a Yang,
I grew up in New Jersey as a Yankee Fan.
It did make me kind of question like,
man, I'm associating with these
neanderthals. Like there is,
there is a certain element
of the, the annoyance of the,
the the casual bandwagon.
Yankee.
One thing we have in common though,
red sox and Yankees,
the level of mouth breathing. I mean when
they, when they cut to the crowd, dude,
but they're was just hanging open.
It's like wholesome looking or whatever.
The west coast has their own vibe.
Florida in the south,
you're lucky if they even show up. Right?
But like you get to the east coast,
Philly, New York, Boston, and we are,
we're animals. And it's literally,
you can't even deny it.
We're just animal.
Oh.
And then as someone who's lived now
in California for about 15 years,
you really start to notice it.
The longer you're away from it,
it stops being normal. And you go back
home and you're like, oh my God, this is,
having said that you can get stabbed
to death at a game on the west coast.
Yeah. That's all. They skipped the
whole dump and the beer over your head.
They just don't write to
a, you know, a homicide.
Yeah, that's, that's the
thing. As an eagles fan, we
always get so much shit. Oh,
you guys are the worst fans.
You guys are mean.
You guys booed Santa Claus
in through Sovos. Meanwhile,
Dodgers fans are putting guys in comas
and stabbing people died over over,
over a Dodgers game. A game that you
know, barely the city cares about.
Weapon of choice for Philadelphia
is the d cell battery and that's,
that's honorable. Not a, not a knife.
What's wrong? Medium. Medium security.
If you go to jail,
yeah.
Yeah.
We don't stop to know.
They had the jail at Eagle Eagle
stadium if they had one out here today,
but we'd have to be, you have
to be a prison. It was the
crime that was committed.
It wouldn't be like some,
some silly drunk and behavior.
Yeah. You're not getting a couple of
days. You're going for a good long time
and the then the Chris Dodger stadium,
you can't even tailgate.
They won't let you drink
beer in our, sorry, if you
could move on to the stadium.
Thank you.
Yeah.
The one time I had a couple beers in
the parking lot was playing some wiffle
ball,
assuming that's kind of what you do
before a baseball game and a guy in a golf
cart came up. Took my id and said I
was on the list. So I dunno what list,
what list I'm on it. You
know what? I should have a,
I should have just said, who the fuck are
you? Why would I give it? Listen, I was,
I was confronted
cop cars. Him, Doris. Yeah.
I don't know how
to work and get your degree there buddy.
Yeah, I don't know. How would
he will determine? Yeah,
it's unclear how we would detain me.
Put me back where the golf clubs are
supposed to be. I mean, in very unclear.
Oh yeah,
yeah. I Dunno. I Dunno. So that's
exciting. Brass tacks here.
Let's talk. Let's talk about
the national football league.
Of course that bill's going
to be making some pics.
He's on the line courtesy of my book.
He died aga,
the official online sports book
of the sports game, like podcasts,
a hundred percent deposit bonus
using the Promo Code bill bets.
First game, uh, that we
got here to select is a,
the eagles minus three
heading into giant stadium.
Nfcs doesn't look great. Eagles
and give mouth breathers. Yeah,
there's gonna be a lot of mouth
breathing going on. All the eagles,
two and three giants, one and for the
NFC east, not looking great bill. Uh,
which way you lean in this game?
I would take the giants with the points.
Oh, okay. I get in three. Yup.
They're a, they're the home three
and I'm going to, I just, you know, those
division rivalry games that they lost,
the giants lost a heartbreaker last
year. I mean, they, they should,
they should be to win orders. What
does it really want? I'm forced to.
They should be a, it was
at two and three. Yeah.
They're not as bad as their
record. And uh, I dunno, I think,
I don't know much about the egos by
imagine. After they won a Superbowl,
a bunch of guys in that team went out
and got that free agency money and some
coaches left.
So there's always a bit of a hangover
trying to figure out who you are after
that. Speaking is a patriots fan
considerably once so many of the century,
you know,
just stick with this for the party.
I mean,
it's not a good sign when there's
multiple book tour going for.
And like I read a backup
quarterback's book in the off season,
so that's maybe the, maybe the TMG did
a little ahead of themselves there.
Yeah, they're still celebrating. Yeah,
they're probably hanging out with the
Vatican there. Paul said that God,
can you believe we want
to do a beer bones?
I would shake uh,
Eli and the points at home.
Alright Kramer, I'm guessing you're
willing. You're going giants men.
I mean it's the same thing we've told
the defense doesn't play as well on the
road. And Carson Wentz,
just like the doctor said,
he's not all the way back and the
offense is struggling. There's no magic.
The head coach is not,
he's that he's not having those magical
fourth down Philly Philly calls and yeah,
like bill said,
giants not as bad.
They got hosed by the rafts
and an awesome cake last week.
So of course I'm on the giants.
Home team is hit home team is called
covered every home Thursday night game.
So that, that's true.
But here's what I'll say.
Eagles 16 and four in the last 20
they have eli Manning's number also.
You, Brian, your giants. What are they
horrible at covering the tie down.
Exactly. But Zachary [inaudible], he's uh,
you know he's those star right
now on offense your nation, Bro.
You're reaching, no, I, I think they go
in. This is a must win for the eagles.
I just don't think this
giants offensive line,
we'll be able to keep the Eagles'
defensive line, which has been struggling.
Such thing as a must win for the ego.
So just one.
Oh, right. I know. That's the problem.
They got a free pass for the rest of
my life, but I I wear or the dog mass.
They're gone. They're not the dog
anymore. They're the targeted,
they are the road favorite
sending champs and they got their
feet up. Take the points. Okay.
Nah, I'm saying I'm saying eagles minus
three road victory. No sweat here.
All right, here's the, here's
an interesting one. Played
Out in Wembley Stadium,
the Seahawks minus three,
I guess technically a home game
for the Raiders. They're fine.
They're playing some real
football out in London. Bill. Uh,
which way you lean in on this game.
Okay.
Well I love John Gruden but I still
don't think he's gotten his team where it
needs to be. And, uh,
Pete Carroll is a beast and I just,
you know,
I don't even think we were playing over
in Europe last time. Gruden coached.
He's got the oldest team in the NFL. They
going to be all cranky from the flight.
I Dunno. I'm thinking what's
this? See what I'm given.
Seahawks are only lane three
only. They don't, like
you just said, only that
I'm already, I'm already
tipping my hand, I guess.
I think, uh, yeah,
I think they're going to have problems
contained in their quarterback.
Gregor's lap problems containing
their ra, the quarterback. It's a,
I'm going to go to Seattle.
I mean, I just want, I want to see the,
I just want to see the
documentary on Gruden in London.
That's all John Gruden said.
Quote,
he's not a good flyer and gets anxious
on long plane rides. Interesting fact.
The Raiders, uh, they're not
flying out to London until Friday,
which I always feel is a bad sign.
Carol, he got on the plane, uh,
you know, a couple of days early. So the
Seahawks are already out in London. I,
I think that's good.
Donny walked around. Buckingham
Palace gone. Whew. Anytime.
Anything good happen. Yes. The ric flair.
He is kind of scary when a,
when a old guy choose that much
gum and has that much energy, it's,
it's a little unsettling.
Okay. What's on real? He's the oldest
coach in the NFL. He looks great.
He looks great though.
He's like the Dick Clark or coaches.
Yeah, he's on my, he's kind of me of Jack
Lalaine. Just like an old guy. Gray hair.
Super jacked. Tons of energy.
He must be juicing. Yeah.
Juice in the positive way.
Teaching counts. Yeah.
Classic Classic Seattle Guy. I listen,
I know you don't want to say, uh,
the Seahawks, that was kind of their
Superbowl ad home against the rams.
They lost that game. That
was a tough loss. Maybe they,
maybe they don't get up for this game,
but I,
I just don't think this
Raiders team is right.
Gruden I think is having trouble
adjusting to the modern game.
He hasn't been able to fix car.
I just don't see the raider showing up
showing up. When's the last time you flew?
Like a nine hour flight and then you
play a game. It's 18 hours later,
but that doesn't seem right.
I usually have to sleep for a
solid eight to 10 hours. Seahawks.
My up thing is that they're,
they're avoiding London.
That's a good thing that could play
to their advantage. Yeah. Any of them.
I'll listen and go there and get
the Indian food. Avoid the actual,
yeah, avoid the food. They actually make
Jon Gruden with a giant
plate of bangers and mash.
Tired to Macedonia English breakfast.
Other than just give a couple of fried ups
blood pudding. Oh yeah.
Super gross sounds. It sounds
delicious. Yeah. I just, I,
I think there's plenty of science and
I'm sure grins not up on the science.
There's plenty of science on
why you want to get there early.
So just knowing that I love the Seahawks.
Yeah.
Good spot for the Seahawks.
Good matchup.
Final game of the three
we're picking with bill here,
the Kansas City chiefs head into New
England for Sunday night football.
Right now the pats
coming off the long rest,
three and a half points home favorites
against the Kansas City chiefs. Yeah.
If favor.
You know what?
This is such a weird game because the
Jaguars manhandled the Patriots and then
Kansas City played the jags like a month
later and Blake Bortles look like he
shouldn't even be in the NFL.
So it's one of those things was like when
the Patriots played the Jag was what,
where the Patriots not as bad
as they seemed. And the Jaguars.
Warren is good or is
Kansas City that good?
MMM.
Oh, three points at home. This is the
thing when I'm going to take the Patriots,
which this makes me nervous.
Yeah. I wouldn't have a
tease this game either. Um,
the only thing that, the only, the
thing that's tipping it is that, uh,
Kansas City has the worst defense.
And I,
I'm not buying last week, even though
they look solid, I'm just not buy out.
I don't know cause I don't think, God,
I don't think our defense is good.
And I was kind of making fun of how much,
you know the attach Oklahoma.
I mean the way the hyper and disco
and Grady has rings show time.
My homes.
I hope you realize what you just saw
it. I saw Brett five do that. 1,000.
Everybody relax. I think it's
cause Brady's going to leave soon.
Droop reason it's going to leave
soon and they, they, they, they're,
they need somebody to, uh, to step it up.
And I think that guy
will step it up. Um, uh,
and they also shellacked us a year ago,
but are there enough guys left
on the team that care? Um,
ready cares and he's got Adelman back
and he stepped to the guy looks to have a
few from Cleveland.
Yeah.
Good Lord. What are you, you know what?
I'm going to go with the Patriot. I can't,
I can't pick my just like people listen,
don't take that as advice.
That's my art talk.
This is a really great time to
sell the chief stock and Sean you,
we like to look at what the public's up
to 68% of the tickets on the chiefs and
yet this line has gone from three to
three and a half. What does that tell you?
[inaudible] is on the Patriots.
The Hook is there to scare you.
Lay the hook. Come on. This is,
this is the classic like hey,
any read beat the shit out of bill
Bellacheck week one last year.
You think Bella check doesn't
remember that. Yeah, I just don't see
there's a monster in September.
The last guy you want to run into
January.
He's a little tired.
He's kind of a monster year round.
Big Fella.
Oh Man.
I always crack up the Koolaid Gif of
him running through the wall or the punt
pass and kick that. They always show
of him going up against other eight,
nine year olds when he was eight, nine
and he was still like twice their size.
Listen, Andy Reid, great. Oh yeah.
I'll have to send you the video.
It's,
it's an all time classic [inaudible]
he's literally two and a half times the
size of all the other kids.
He's,
he's a good coach, but the pads,
they have that extra rest. Uh,
and I think they kind of figured
out their offense and the chiefs,
the defensive backfield is not right.
Like the Jag's office on the
road is way different than, uh,
than the pats at home. So,
uh, I think the patriots,
they covered the three and a half.
Yeah.
I think. How would you play a different
difference when you're on the road?
They're worried about some
guy dressed up like Boba Fett.
Oh my God. The face paint threw me off.
I think really what it is is uh, they,
they talk so much about how the snap
count makes a huge difference where the
offense that they're going up
against when they're at home,
they have to go on silent
count a lot and it's,
it's much easier to get a better jump on
the ball when you're on the road. The,
the crowd noise is against you and a,
I think it makes,
and not to mention it's those late
nights cause you're on the road,
which means you're probably dabbling in
some side action. Lawrence Taylor style,
the prostitutes coming to the hotel.
I don't know if you can do that
now with cell phone cameras.
Oh that's true. That's
true. It's a real, it's a,
it's a simpler back when lt could just,
every team has a ray Donovan.
I'm sure of that.
It does seem like there's,
there's probably some still a shenanigans
going on. Kramer close things out here.
Are you on the paths as well? Yeah,
no, I'm definitely, I think, you know,
I like to play,
I play against the market and I think
everyone sees the chiefs and like bill was
saying like Pat Ma homes can do no wrong.
Uh,
he's the greatest thing
since exactly the left kit,
the reaction to the
lefthanded throw was like, Yo,
I manning has three of
those in his career.
Like that's not a sign of a great actress.
He's already a legend.
So, and now their comparison
comparing him to Steph curry and it's,
it's a little bit like no
one's willing to say it,
but like are we just saying this
because he's light skinned all,
I mean it was a light skinned black
guy with curly hair and all of a sudden
they're the same play and nothing.
Nothing like Steph curry at all.
Like how was slinging 80
mile an hour fastball?
Football's anything shooting a three
pointer. Nothing. I, anyway, good. Sorry.
Good time to sell on the paths or sorry,
selling the tools.
The chiefs I'm buying in the past.
You could have gotten the pats to win
that division a week or two ago for like
minus 300. It's now minus 900
Sean. Oh Man. See send money.
Easy money every year. Oh, he's
just passing up on the paths.
The when the division just, it's better
than any sort of stack you can invest in.
All right bill, before we
let you go, throw out a, uh,
throw it a lock for a week.
Six here in the NFL.
God, I didn't have a chance to
look at it so I got to go outside.
I don't know any, any other sort
of a lead pipe predictions that you
for this weekend patriots beat Kansas
City will then be odds on favorite to win
the Superbowl we lose to Kansas City.
They'll start asking,
is this Brady's last year?
That's my lock.
Lock it up. I like it. Has
he fallen off the cliff?
Wouldn't be the first time
the chiefs chief's defeat
of the Patriots turned into,
is this the end for Brady's is the end.
It's got to end sometime.
Could this be the year? And he's
doing, he's got that trainer.
He'll be good for awhile.
Heminger Eric it
spongy muscle or have
you heard about that?
It's not all hard and all tight
and everything. It's like,
you know when you're
going to do the dishes,
you know that little sponge malleable.
That's Tom Brady's and go watch this dude.
Run the 40 at the combine and tell me he's
not a better athlete at 41. Like what,
what something's going on. Come
on, something's going on. He's,
he's getting younger as time goes
on. But uh, yeah, have clearly the
Colby thing, he probably got his
blood spawn some stem cells in there,
a couple of embryos.
He uses that as a pillow or something.
I don't know what he's doing.
He looks amazing.
Sure does. All right, well, uh, Bill,
appreciate you calling in. As always,
make sure you guys check out.
F is for family season three
coming out in November on Netflix.
Vince Vaughn joining the cast and a as
always, appreciate you calling him bell.
All right guys, thanks so much
for having me. I appreciate it.
Once again, Bill burr brought to you by
the good folks over at my bookie. Dot.
Agee, the official online sports
book of the sports gambling podcasts.
Use that Promo Code Bill bets
for a 100% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid over
at my bookie. Dot. Agee
is that time
it's going on. It's Belper and it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 11th, 2010. How the hell
are you? Are you doing good?
Well that's good.
Um,
I had all this shit that I wanted to talk
about and then I was looking at these
fucking emails and right off the
Bat I got one from Lo and behold,
douche bag or the fucking week.
Guy's name is Brad courses.
Fucking names Brad.
You know what else?
What?
What a what a mother and
father name a Douche bag baby.
Other than Brad. Yeah.
This is from Brad. Bill.
I was hoping that I could
find your podcast on Itunes,
yet another week passes by where your
fans can not listen to your show.
No problem with that. Right
to that. Then he goes,
you might want to make that
a priority sometime too.
I could just fucking see his bare
feet and his fucking penny loafers.
What are you leaning on my
cubicle? You fucking cunt. Really?
Do I really want to make that a priority?
You dumb.
Fuck you don't think I'm not
trying to contact iTunes.
They don't have a fucking
person who answers their phones.
They ignore my God damn emails. What am
I supposed to do? Go down to main street,
right down on main street
to the fucking mom and pop.
Fucking Mr Mrs Itunes store.
It doesn't exist. You do? Okay.
You might want to make that
a priority s fucking soon.
I want to slap you right
and your privilege.
Fucking Connecticut white face.
And I don't give a fuck if you're not
white and even not from Connecticut,
cause you should be with that fucking
tone. What a cunt con to the week.
Brad, go fuck yourself. All right.
I'm trying to get distinct back up on
iTunes. They're not responding to me.
What am I supposed to do?
They don't have a location.
This is the exact shit I've been
fucking trying to tell you guys about.
It starts with those God damn automated
machines down at the fucking grocery
store.
You siding with the fucking robots.
Some of that made sense. You know it
did. Seriously, this is the future.
This is what a store is going to be.
You're not going to be able to
get in contact with anybody.
You're going to have a problem and
you can basically go fuck yourself.
And then some other fucking nerd whose
only job is going to be fucking grease
the elbow with a fucking robot that took
his job is going to send me an email.
Tell me that I need to
make something a priority.
Why don't you go fuck yourself buddy.
Why don't you,
why don't you make that a priority?
Sometimes soon. All right.
What about FAU?
I swear to God you are.
You might want to make that
a priority sometime soon. Oh,
the fucking stuffed shirt.
Fucking hang you by your God damn tie.
Brad. You fucking cunt. Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm glad you told all your friends to
listen to it and now they can't. Huh?
What's that fucking with
you and your God Damn Ego.
Do you have a position at work?
Little fucking corner office. Brad
fucking moron telling
me I need to breathing.
You might want to make that a priority
once you tell me something fucking else
obvious. All right,
there you go. This year,
a head of steam for the week Douche
bag of the week. Good old bread.
I had no idea.
Really.
If it wasn't on iTunes and people
couldn't download it in anymore,
like that would present some sort of
a problem and drop my listenership.
You'd think, I don't realize
that Brad, you fucking Dick
on Columbus Day.
Can't believe I'm in this kind of
a fucking move on Columbus Day.
You know this is a great day
in sort of white history.
When that Spaniard came over here,
who kind of look white because of his
brown hair. Did he have brown hair?
Wasn't he Spanish or did he just
sail for the Spanish? I can't eat.
I can't even fucking keep the
damn story straight. All right.
In My fucking history book.
He had yellow hair, you know,
and shiny teeth in a fucking,
you know,
he was in shape. Then all of a sudden
they make a movie about him as Jerrad dip,
not dude.
And he played them that French fuck.
He played him and he didn't
even land in Florida. He lands,
he leans down in the,
uh,
the Caribbean starts cutting people's
hands off because they're not finding
blood diamonds. So, which
was it? You know what I love?
I love when like, when they have like
a, like a story. Everybody's going by,
right about some shit that
happened fucking 500 years ago,
whatever thousand years ago.
Then out of nowhere,
there'll be a show on TV and they'll
say new evidence suggests new evidence.
Five something from 500 years
and yet new evidence. Really?
What the fuck did you find it that did
Christopher Columbus write something down
on a cocktail napkin in a bar and
somebody finally cleaned out the fucking,
those rubber mats that they stand on
and they found it. Oh look at this.
Evidently he went down to the Caribbean
and chop people's hands off and for some
reason wrote it all over this
cocktail napkin. You know,
I see some, you know where we
thought the world was flat.
New evidence suggest that maybe he
didn't sail off the edge of the world.
Maybe his fucking boat sank in a storm.
I can see that.
That's sort of new
evidence, but I mean, what,
what sort of new evidence did you find?
Huh?
Some fucking old lady used to bang,
I guess when she was fucking not
even a fetus and she's still alive.
I actually knew Christopher Columbus.
He was a murderer at son of a bitch.
I don't know who the
fuck knows what happened.
I just like bringing that shit up so
then people who were into that stuff can
then send me a five page email,
you know,
or the lazy ones who then just search it,
find it and then paste the
link like they're an expert.
I'm lashing out at everybody this week.
It's Christopher Columbus Day. Everybody,
you know, and thank God he
discovered America or else
we wouldn't have been here.
Think about what would have happened,
what wouldn't have happened if he
didn't come over here? You know,
from slavery to cheesecake factory's,
none of that would have been a possibility
if that fucking greedy son of a bitch.
They actually took a lot of balls.
He, I think he's the first x
Gamer. You know what I mean?
He just said, fine. He's that
really is. Was he a scientist?
Where did Christopher Columbus get the
balls? Because I'll tell you right now,
me being the afraid of technology
person that I am afraid of change,
you know, there's no fucking
way I would've gotten that boat.
There's no god damn way.
I know the world's round and I
won't get on a fucking boat today.
What do you think about that?
Are you afraid that it's
going to sink bill? Yes, I am.
That's what I'm afraid of it.
I'm afraid I'm going to survive it and
then sit there and pray that hypothermia
sets in in numbs me up,
so I don't feel it when the fucking
tiger shark starts nibbling on one of my
fucking pasty thighs.
I'm sorry guys.
This is really fucking angry.
That guy just really set me off where
the devacy exact fucking reason why I
became a goddamn comedian.
Cause I don't want to ever be in a
position where some douche comes over,
leans over into my life and tells me
what I might want to make a fucking
priority. You condescending? Fuck.
What kind of a mouse of
a woman did you marry?
It's probably downstairs right now making
a Voodoo doll or you and your fucking
Docker's he fat gut hanging out.
You went to Lowe's guys.
Huh?
You always got to wear this sport coat
and no one knows how fat you are until
till they have the office.
Fucking let's go play Frisbee party and
then you show up with your fucking man.
Tits, heart disease buddy.
That's what I wish on you.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Listen to another podcast.
You might want to make that a priority.
All right,
so let's get on with the hyping
for this week. I have, um,
I have a new show that I actually
have heaven even hyped on here. Uh,
it's the last second. I'm going to
be at the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts,
and I am doing a comedy show actually
from my brother who was running for state
Senate in Massachusetts.
And A,
all proceeds will go after we
paid for the theater. And uh,
the state tax had a though, you know, God
knows what else you got to pay, but all,
all the proceeds are going to go towards,
uh, helping him out with his campaign.
So, um, that's it. All right.
It's going to be October 20th
at the Wilbur Theater in,
uh, Boston, Massachusetts.
So come on down,
come on down and uh,
watch me dance around like a
monkey for a fucking hour and uh,
we'll raise some money for my brother's
campaign. There you go. There you go.
You know,
you might want to make that a priority.
I'm not gonna be able to get
that out of my fucking head.
That's the exact reason.
That's why I worked in,
that's why I worked in the warehouse.
I never went into the carpeted area
because I saw those fucking people.
They had to sit there
at that Goddamn desk.
And you just saw you saw the back of their
necks when you came. He said, you know,
Hey Mike,
he saw their shoulders come up a little
bit because they thought it was that
cunt in the office who leans over to
tell him what they might want to make a
fucking priority.
All right.
Okay. I am back. Um,
let's talk NFL football.
Everybody, let's fucking just drive
that subject into the Goddamn ground.
Shall We? Um, now fuck that. We'll
get to that a little bit later. Um,
let's talk about online
banking, shall we? I, yeah,
but was listening to am radio this week.
You know why? Cause I'm a big
fan of the fill Henry show.
So I was listening to that and I just
woke up the next day and I still had it on
that. And uh, you know,
there was this one show where this
guy was as left as Fox is, right?
And it was just,
it was completely asinine.
And he was making the usual
statements that idiots make who,
who hosts those shows or
listen to those shows.
He started saying something
dumb about like, uh,
you know when Republicans lie
in Washington, no one cares.
Nobody does anything about it.
But if a Democrat lies,
they just hold their feet to the fire.
You know, that dumb shit. You know,
they can do whatever they want, but if
we do something, but they, but they,
he was like, really? You don't think
that you're so far to one side that you,
maybe you're,
you're just a little bit clouded and your
vision keyed out really fucking notice.
Like a sports fan,
you know,
look a Yankee Fan,
right?
Some fucking eight year old pole's
a routine fly ball into the stands.
As long as it's a home run for your
team, you don't give a fuck. Right?
Then all of a sudden if someone on
the other team is fucking around,
then it's a major God damn problem.
Like every fan I should've just picked
on the Yankee fans should I have,
I'll tell you, that was an amazing victory
they had over the twins. You see that?
They fucking swept those sons
of bitches right in, in the rug.
How'd you like that? Minnesota
with the new stadium. Uh,
what do you think that was going to make
a difference? Maybe if we play outside,
we won't get our asses kicked.
Do you understand that you're a mom and
pop store out there and you're going up
against Walmart.
All right.
Get your grandmother off the front
porch with a shotgun. It's fucking over.
Um,
this is how much I don't watch baseball.
I thought the reds were in last place
like they have been for like the last 10
years. So it was kind of exciting
to see them in first. And you know,
playing in the playoffs,
although the Phillies was spanking
their fucking head. I don't know.
I got a weird relationship
with Cincinnati. They'd
beat my red sox in 1975.
It's one of the first memories
I have of being a sports fan.
I didn't really know what was going on.
I just remember hearing my dad
screaming at the fucking TV. Um,
so they beat us then. But then I know
I kind of liked, I always liked, uh,
I live is a big national
league fan in the 80s.
I liked the astro turf people stole basis.
I thought,
I thought astro turf was cool.
That's how much of a child of the
70s and eighties I was. But um,
I dunno now they're back
kind of rooting for them,
but I had such a shitty weekend last
time I was out there and fucking Norfolk,
Kentucky and being in downtown Cincinnati
where there was just absolutely
nothing going on plus past 5:00 PM that
you want to be involved in. So I dunno,
I think I'm rooting for the Phillies.
Is that my team?
Obviously anybody who plays the fucking
Yankees I'm going to root against,
but you know, uh, you son of a bitch.
You guys want to hear me take a phone
call? Huh? Business phone call. Hello?
What's going on Josh?
How are you?
Do I sound odd right
now it's because I'm a,
I'm in the middle of doing my podcast
and you're not really on the air.
You're,
you're up to my ear so no
one can really hear anything.
So if you want to trash these fucking
morons, then I'm morons. You know,
it was just one person pissed me off,
told me something that I need to
make a priority on my podcast.
And suddenly I felt like I had a day job.
You want to email me those flights and
that stuff and I'll look at it after the
podcast.
Oh, Jesus. Okay.
All right. Hang on one second.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on.
All right, I'm back. Sorry. That's
her not to be way more important.
I thought he was going to say, do you
want to fly to Seattle at this hour,
this hour? Um, and he was,
what the hell was I talking about?
God dammit.
He's talking about Democrats, Republicans
at J. Habitated dad who gives a fuck.
Let's talk about, oh, it's talking
about baseball, but basically,
I don't even know what's
going on in there.
I know Mariano Rivera Rivera's still
playing, right? He still comes out.
They play a little enter Sandman. You
know, he doesn't even like that song.
I'll fucking funny. Is it? Huh? Um, Bill,
it's actually not funny.
Kind of like the last three
minutes of this fucking
podcast. Ah, right. All right.
All right, let's, let's, uh, let's
move on with some subjects here.
Do I have anything? How
about we talk about, um,
Sung about Randy Moss
getting fucking traded
by the Goddamn patriots. This is, um,
I dunno what the fuck I was like,
she's going to say there,
I'm looking at like 15 different things
right now. People. That's what I need.
I need to regroup. All
right. First of all,
I had a weird week football cause
this week my team had a by, you know,
and it's just such like a fucking,
I don't know, it's the weirdest guy.
It's like that Phantom Limb
Syndrome you give, reaching forward.
It's just not fucking there.
You know?
I'll like when you go to a mall and you
can't remember where the fuck you parked
and you just spend enough
God damn hour just searching,
riding around the golf cart with
that fucking security guard.
The alarm key. Pressy lumpy.
You'd think I'm not doing that.
You think I'm not doing
that? Um, so anyways, yeah,
the Patriots Traded Randy Moss.
So I got a bunch of emails from the
happy jet fans and they're sitting there
going like,
Duh,
what do they fucking morons with the
fuck would you thought they'd go fucking
fucking Ned for?
And I think it's the obvious.
I think he was a, I think he's being
a problem in the fucking locker room.
Why else would you trade him?
Why would you trade Randy Moss
for a fucking third round pick?
Why would you do that?
What level of a country would you have
to be in order to make that happen?
And I know what a lot
of people are gonna say,
well the Patriots are saying we
never had a fucking problem with.
What do you think they're going to say?
They're trying to get that out
of their fucking locker room.
So I actually haven't had this big back
and forth with this dude cause I was
trying to talk to him about like he was
trying to tell me how fucking dumb it
was that the Patriots traded that
guy. And I'm just, it's just like,
haven't you seen tios?
Haven't you seen Stephon Marbury is,
you haven't seen these guys. They've
got all the talent in the fucking world,
but they don't dare.
They're not even focused on
whether they're winning or losing.
They're just looking at their fucking
stats and when halftime comes around,
if they don't have their
fucking 15 points already,
are there five fucking catches or
somebody else has more catches in them?
They start acting cunty,
which affects the mood in,
in, in the, in the goddamn locker room.
So I was talking to a student about
team chemistry fucking intangibles,
which he thought was ridiculous.
He's like,
are you one of these people who talks
about intangibles? It doesn't matter.
It's all about what you
do on the fucking field.
Really intangibles was the reason why
I knew Peyton manning wasn't as good as
Tom Brady when it really came down to it,
because that guy is far as dropping back,
throwing a ball,
making a completion, has
it all over. Tom Brady,
he's at least 30% better
in all of those categories.
His stats are at least 30% better.
But the fucking intangible is what goes
on between your fucking ears when the
pressure is on and all of a
sudden it fucking counts in.
The whole season's on the line.
What do you do?
Do you drive your team down for a score
or do you throw a fucking pick six?
Do you lead your team to victory or do
you lose to the eight and eight chargers?
If you're frustrated,
do you fucking hold it in and turn it
into something positive and lead your team
or do you openly show it?
Like I saw him do again yesterday
against the Kansas City chiefs.
He had Peyton face,
I can't get to pull work.
Yeah, why don't you a bitch again
and get a new fucking rule chain.
So Kansas City can't play fucking
defense on you. Did you guys notice?
Kansas City has Romeo,
Carmel and Charlie Weiss.
They basically have our
offensive and defensive
coordinator from back in the day.
Smart sons of bitches over there and
they were doing the exact same shit that
the patriots used to do.
They just didn't have the personnel
to do it for 60 fucking minutes.
And Peyton had the exact same fucking
look on his face that he had from o two o
three Oh four when he couldn't
beat the fucking patriots.
That sir is what I'm talking about.
That's why people say Derek Jeter is
better than a rod despite a rods fucking
stats. I'm telling you, Derek Jeter,
I w you can build a team around that
can't build a team around fucking a rod.
You know, during the moment when
he's supposed to be getting,
you know he's supposed to,
you know,
you don't have three game fucking losing
streak and you need the captain to step
up. You know, say something.
Get the guys going.
Ea Rods over in the corner
putting fucking lip balm on.
It's not a Goddamn leader.
He's over there staring at
himself in the fucking mirror.
I Dunno the fuck are you going to
say, you know, look, this is what,
this is how I look at it.
If you trade a guy as good as Randy Moss
for a third round pick out of fucking
nowhere, he did something so Kentucky
that they just said, you know what?
It's like the lock,
the door test and a Bronx tale.
He did something and this was
just the tip of the iceberg.
We're fucking out and you know, didn't
you know deep in your heart patriots fan?
Didn't you know that? Eventually it
does it ever end good with Randy?
Has he ended well with any
team member with the Vikings?
Yeah. I take a few plays off, you know,
goes out to Oakland cause they're
like, oh, this guy's a headcase.
We always take on head cases and then
all of a sudden they become good guys.
He for fucking problem there. And
he did the same thing out here. So,
so what are you going to do
the fuck you going to do?
What do you think the Patriots were going
to win it if you've seen our defense,
even though we beat the fucking dolphins,
didn't we look like we were in a prevent
defense from the fucking first quarter
on? So, um, I dunno,
I'm not that fucking freaked out about
it considering when I look at the
receivers that we had
when we won super bowls,
we didn't have a Jerry Rice level.
Yeah.
Unless you think David Patton was that
guy, man, I don't fucking know. Whatever.
We have a goddamn system.
You have to, bottom line is,
is Randy's a fucking headcase and
the Patriots are an arrogant miserly
franchise.
Okay.
So we don't tolerate
looking at week like I,
the Patriot stole fucking tolerate you
being a cunt in the locker room. And uh,
okay. I think he was done the second he
had that stupid fucking press conference
saying,
I think there's people here in New
England that don't want to see me do well.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Go take your fucking Goddamn
tampons and go to fucking Minnesota.
And you know what he's going to do out
there tonight, you think? I don't know.
He's not going to get 180
fucking yards tonight.
He's going to do exactly what Manny
did when he went to the Dodgers.
He's going to try for like fucking six
weeks because he wants to pee, you know,
show everybody.
He's not the guy that he fucking is,
but eventually that'll all
go south. You know, Jesus.
What a cluster fuck tonight
is, Huh? Randy Moss in town.
You got Rex Ryan,
he's talked to all that shit and uh,
Brett Farve showed everybody his dick.
Okay,
I know what a lot of you
are probably thinking.
How fucking stupid do you have to
be this day and age to be famous?
Take a picture of your unit and
fucking send it to somebody.
How fucking dumb do you have to be?
I'm telling you right now,
you're looking at it the wrong way.
All right?
What you really have to see is the
level of ass that you get when you play
quarterback for football team.
What you see in Brett Farve
because my first thing was like
when he did that, I was just like,
well why didn't he just fucking
verbally close the deal?
Why didn't he just go up,
talk some shit and make her laugh,
get her fucking number and then
go out with her? Brett Farve,
I like wrangler jeans. You want
to see my Dick? I mean, like what?
What kind of fucking gate?
And then I mean,
it was like this guy has no fucking
game with women because he never had to.
He's Jesus, like to classic. All
American fucking Dudley do right face.
And he's the quarterback of the team.
Probably from junior high on
chicks would just coming to him.
Oh my God, Brad. I got
God. It's bad. Far. Brad,
how did you choose? Thank you.
Thank you. Won't see my deck.
Where's he from? Mississippi. You
can do that still in Mississippi.
You can walk down the street and get
a deck hanging out of your overalls.
No one gives a shit. Yeah.
Mortar Dick hanging out.
You want to go fishing?
They don't give a shit
this whole fucking career. He's been the
fucking man. And when you're the man,
the fucking who is,
don't give a shit.
They take, they take fucking
stampede. You. I bet.
I bet that that was his game.
Just like fucking Ben Roethlisberger.
I'm starting to think that that
guy wasn't a goddamn sex offender.
I just think he's been the quarterback.
He's been the man, so he has no game.
So he just walks into a bar and he's like,
and he just reaches over and grabs them.
Okay.
So, uh, I don't think that those guys
are morons. I look at them the same way.
When people look at someone who
grew up in the inner city, you know,
and they didn't have
access to, to the, to the,
to the good books in their
school was a fucking war zone.
And if you stuck anybody in there,
they also would come out and would
it be at a fucking, you know,
seventh grade reading level,
right?
The same way with me or anybody else.
If I was the fucking man,
if I was the quarterback from
fucking junior high on, oh,
I'd be hanging out at Hooters
just grabbing titties.
You want to see my Dick?
I loved that he did that. I
loved that he did that. You know,
cause you see him do all that shit
on TV and you like Jesus Christ.
I couldn't hit a golf ball as far as
that guy can throw a fucking football.
What happened to me genetically?
What the fuck is wrong with me?
And then Brett Farve does something,
like daddy takes a picture of his
Dick and then sends it to somebody.
And it's just like a,
I dunno,
you know, it's just, there's something,
uh, it's just fucking hilarious.
So evidently they're going to do these
stupid pink uniforms for the rest of the,
I mean, how are you not aware of, of
breast cancer at this point? You know,
Goddamn Nfl, don't you have
enough fans? Yeah, we'll,
we'll,
we'll even appeal to fucking women
with breast cancer show that we care.
You know,
it's a fucking,
you know what to say and I
know that sounds fucking mean,
but I'm telling you that was
how that decision was made.
And I know because I
wasn't in the meeting,
I just lump all corporations into the
same shit bag. That's what I do. Um,
all right, here's a guy actually says a
underrated overrated this week. He said,
uh, he, and he's talking about
this shit shit. He was saying, um,
over rate of breast cancer is a terrible
thing, but why does it take precedent?
Oh,
a over all other forms of cancer to the
point where everyone in the NFL has to
spend a month of October looking
like they're in the heart foundation.
All for the sake of breast cancer
awareness. Who isn't aware?
It's the number one
killer of women were told.
Apparently though it's actually number
seven behind 606 are the things that men
also die of.
Well that's interesting.
So I guess they meet, it's the number
one killer of women only. I Dunno.
Granted men do in rare cases
also get breast cancer, but uh,
it's clearly not about them.
I don't think anyone could get,
go to go through a benefit for a man
with breast cancer without giggling a
little. Uh, what's the number one
killer of men? I have no idea.
No one does prostate cancer.
September is prostate,
prostate cancer awareness month,
which I didn't know until I googled it.
Prostate cancer needs the breast
cancer PR team, uh, colon cancer,
they get a brown ribbon to quote my
friend Nate, can you think of a more,
I don't give a shit color than Brown.
So there you go. Yeah. You know,
I thought it was cool last
year that they did it,
but it's like every year are they
going to be wearing pink? You know,
I just, you know, with the fucking,
every given he's got a goddamn ribbon.
You know what's funny is when they did
it last year, it actually had effect.
You know, where I was just like, oh,
what the, what the fuck are they wearing?
Pink for? Oh, breast cancer
awareness. And then then it's over.
Then it's over and now you're making
jaws two and no one gives a shit, right?
Spielberg isn't directing. It's over.
It's over. We got it. We're aware.
We are aware of, all right.
Overrated. Uh, the Foa.
Harris Full Hawk style.
The only reason it's overrated
is because you don't,
you don't have a segment on
your podcast called fucking gay.
If you want a Mohawk, that's cool.
Just man up and do it the right way.
So there you go. There you go. I
got to meet guys. You know what?
For the last 10 minutes, I felt like I
had absolutely nothing to talk about.
I don't know what's going on in my life.
I'm thinking about buying a fucking house.
Let's talk about my life for a second.
I'm thinking about buying a fucking
house out here and I live in a bankrupt
state in a city that technically has no
water supply and they want about 1.2 to
one point $4 million for anything
remotely fucking decent out here.
And uh, um, I can't do it.
I'm not, you know, it's fun.
I'm not going to be one point
something million dollars in debt.
I'll be on the road for the
rest of my fucking life.
So I've been going on the Internet
and I've been looking at places, um,
in the middle of nowhere,
and I've been trying to figure out how
I can live in the middle of fucking
nowhere without a losing my mind and be
somehow still existing in this business.
And I realized I can't fucking do it.
You know
how many movie stars
live in Fucking Wyoming?
I know they got ranches out there,
but they wait til they're fucking
famous before they go out there.
I don't know what the fuck
I'm going to do. God dammit.
I'm a typical fucking American.
You know what you think I want some
little ass fucking house. I don't,
I want to fuck and spread.
I want a big ass God damn house.
I want a fucking pool inside and outside.
I want a god damn.
I know what I want and it's
going to be fucking ridiculous.
But uh, you know what's
funny is you, if, if,
whatever your job is, if it doesn't
involve you having to be there,
like these people who work
from home on their computers,
you can actually have an
MTV cribs level house.
You just have to live in like fucking,
you know,
the upper east corner of Montana.
You know,
granted you're going to get attacked by
a fucking bobcat every time you go out
to try to fucking grill a hot dog.
Oh fuck.
What the fuck are you going to do?
You guys want to some youtube
videos for the week yet? Well,
I don't give a shit if you don't
because here they come. All right,
youtube a and r l gets knocked out.
Um,
this is a referee getting
knocked out and a,
I think it's rugby and you got to see
this because the guy who knocks out
inadvertently knocks out the referee.
Might be one of the most unathletic I
don't athletic guys I've ever seen in my
life.
He looks like some guy in times square
who's trying to charge you too much for a
fucking digital camera and
he's got a fat round face.
If he had any sort of athletic ability,
he would have been able to jump over the
ref instead of kneeing him in the back
of the fucking,
when I got to tell you something,
this unathletic Douche bag,
he knocks this ref the fuck out.
Like I'm surprised this guy didn't die.
This fucking pudgy jackass is running
full speed and it's the most pathetic
attempt to hurdle.
This guy couldn't hurdle a fucking
tube sock and he's trying to hurt this
fucking kid and he just, Ah,
you know, when you know
that, you know, you know the,
the form you have when your hurdle
one legs outstretched in the yellow,
one's bent, it's the bent knee and
he's got all that fucking pudgy wait,
come in and he just fucking knees and
right in the back of the head and that guy
just goes limp. Um, all right.
This is one,
this one is actually funny and scary.
It's called a Turkish
guy goes bananas and,
uh,
I believe he screams a law and he
looks like he attempts to do that.
You ever see those people?
Uh,
like the break dancers or whatever the
fuck they are or dancers in general.
And they do that thing with a
jump up in the air, like sideways,
like a deer and sort
of do like a three 60,
they'll almost like parallel to the
ground and then they somehow land and they
jump up and they do it again. This guy is
basically doing that, but he's too fat,
not a shape.
So he's just sort of,
he's just sort of rolling
around on the ground,
but he gets his legs and his arms
out. It's a pretty, uh, he's very, uh,
sorta Belushi esque where he's punchy,
but he's very light on his feet. Um,
is another great one.
This is about as rock and roll as it gets.
Swedish singer vomits during performance.
It's just phenomenal.
The type of music he's singing,
the fact that he doesn't stop the fact
that he's singing like that death metal,
like ordered Rah Rah Rah.
And then occasionally he'd be like,
and then he actually is puking
as he's going. It's awesome. Um,
loud car horn prank.
These are all things that you can
search or you can also also go to the
[inaudible] podcast.com and we'll
have all of these, the official,
the [inaudible],
podcast.com,
the official fan webpage of the Monday
morning podcast that is no longer on
iTunes. Okay. I don't know
what else I'm supposed to do.
We've called these people,
we've emailed them,
they have not gotten back
to us and they're probably,
I'm going to get served some sort of
papers for stocking at this point.
Cause that's what I feel like.
I feel like it was a girl that I went out.
I had a good time. Evidently
she didn't. And um,
you know, I went through the
whole roommate lying to me phase,
you know. Hello? Yeah. Hey,
it's bill. Is iTunes there?
I yeah, no. Um,
I tunes in the shower. Oh yeah.
Dina, do you know when, when,
when they're going to be
out? Oh, I dunno. It's funny.
Nine minutes. Why did I say 20? Yeah,
29 minutes.
Okay.
Fucking half hour later age.
Which bill is iTunes there?
Um, yeah, no, they're still in the shower
but doing that for fucking
two weeks and uh, you know,
it's that classic classic fucking
corporate shit where they have themselves
completely insulated. We'll get back
to you if we fucking feel like it.
Itunes, we own the tunes. Fucking cunt.
You know, I saw, I think when I was
listening on am radio. Dot. Even,
did I already talk about this or
did I start to talk about this?
They were talking about online banking.
Okay.
The shit member back in the day
when I was talking about that going,
you have to be out of your fucking mind
to pay bills or to do any sort of online
banking because someone's going to steal
your identity and take all the money
out of your bank account. Well, guess
what? That's exactly what's happening.
All these morons who sent me emails going,
dude,
I don't even have to go to the post stuff.
I don't have to lick a fucking stamp.
It's so fucking easy.
That's what I love about computers.
Everything's so fucking easy.
And then you get raped in the ass
and then they then, then no one ever
addresses it is that goes, hey, maybe,
maybe back in the day it
was a little bit better.
Like people sitting there going,
uh,
they were talking about when I
was bitching about that. Go on.
I don't pay bills online.
I'm not having all that information
online for any fucker in the world who has
an ability to hack into
shit to come after my stuff.
I just don't want that to happen. And
then these fucking morons it going well.
What a book to guide
you on the post office.
Like that guy has access to the entire
fucking world down the post office.
And even though he does
have access to my shit,
there's actually cameras on those
people and yeah, he might get me,
but they're going to get him.
They get those guys.
And those guys go to fucking jail as
opposed to someone on the Internet who can
look at everybody's shit once they
break into it. So I have a deadly,
they're saying that if you are dumb
enough to bank online that they're saying
don't use the same computer that uh,
that you bank with tea
to do like email with.
Cause evidently that's how they get in.
I have no idea.
But someone told me awhile ago that
all my information is already up on the
fucking Internet anyways
because my country bank put
it up there just in case I
want to, I want to bank
on line. It's like, no,
it's not just in case it's cause you're
phasing out fucking cash and this is the
direction you're taking my money.
I don't know man. I have a real, I got
a real fucking problem with banks. Hey,
what's up? What are you laughing at?
Nia is here. Everybody come on in.
I this has just been a
real negative podcasts.
Come over here.
You just had a what?
I just had a great conversation with
somebody. Oh yeah. Did they tell you,
you know, you needed to make anything
a priority? No, they didn't. Okay.
Who were you talking to?
An actress and she was just positive
and awesome and it was great.
I need to do on your phone. Can I ask
you a question? Why are you with me?
Why am I, why are you fucking with me? I'm
fucking like this curmudgeonly old man.
I'm sitting here going off
on online baking and I,
and I realized I got halfway through it
that I really didn't have enough facts
and am radio one the other day and I
felt like I knew something. I don't know.
Why am I with you? I love
you. Jesus. Get out of here.
Wow.
It's supposed to be funny.
Yes. It's supposed to be funny. Oh, so
I'm supposed to say something clever.
I think the moment passed. I think the
moment past, the moment passed. All right,
well that's great. You had a
nice positive. What do you,
what are you gonna do now?
Eat something healthy.
Okay.
Say a load of the bobcat's.
Ah,
she hates me right now. Nia. I thought
you were going to come over and trash me.
That's your job on the podcast and I
supposed to come over and tell me you love
me. All right. You know something.
This podcast started
out with such promise,
kind of like Randy Moss.
You know we went 16 at, Oh,
here we go.
We're going to fucking undefeated season.
Oh fuck. 18 and one. Wow. Whatever.
There's next year. Tom Brady
gets his knee blown out. Fuck.
All right, Tom Brady's coming back. We
get raped by the fucking ravens. Wait,
this is actually a patriots thing.
I was starting off with Randy Moss and
then Randy starts fucking pouty with is
itchy God damn beard.
What a fucking moron.
You know? Who knows? Maybe he'll become
a great analyst like Keyshawn Johnson.
Keyshawn Johnson was the greatest one
I ever saw were Tampa Bay just sent him
home. They didn't even try to get anything
for him. They were just like, yeah,
Kesha, why don't you just leave?
Just fucking, just go home.
What life for the rest of the
day? No, for good. Just just go.
And then I saw him later on that night
on ESPN and he was wearing like a USC
Jersey and he completely could give
a fuck and a, it was just, you know,
then it turned out to be a great analyst.
All right,
let's continue with the Youtube
Shit. A loud car. Horn prank.
A woman's segway crash is a great one.
If you always wanted to punch a woman
but didn't want to go to jail for it,
you can at least watch one. Basically
Punch herself with the floor of a hotel.
Um, and gay hipster
fight. That's a great one.
Gay hipster fight. Evidently
that's a got a ton of hits. Uh,
let's get back to the fucking,
let's just try and go with some topics
and maybe I can pull myself out of the
mud here.
Um,
this was called Dick at work bill.
I work with a hoarder on top of that.
Uh,
the dude seems to pride himself on saying
deuce chilling stuff that makes your
head shake.
He's also one of those guys that throws
everyone else under the bus when he's
called out by the manager for his mess.
Example of Douche chilling sayings.
The first day,
the first day we were
in our current office,
he walks up to a group of and
sees that we're doing the,
getting to know you banter.
He opens up with a,
suppose it's story from his frat days
that ended up with him naked with,
with a Manet's jar.
Jesus Christ example.
I like how this guy is just really
very efficient example of under the bus
throwing.
Okay.
Commencing example of under, under the
bus throwing. All right, here we go.
When he was told why he has so much stuff.
MMM.
When he was told why he has so much stuff,
he pointed out my friends cubicle. Oh,
when he was asked, do you mean when he
was asked why he have so much stuff?
I guess in his work area,
he pointed out my friends cubicle
that had a bunch of Batman stuff,
tastefully decorating the desk and wall.
Someone else had Mickey mouse
stuff, uh, in the same way,
which he dismissed as Disneyland.
Always one of those guys.
He's like Coby Bryan.
Well, Shaq rapes girls too.
Remember that fucking cunt.
MMM.
So first of all, can we get
to your friends who have, uh,
I can see if a female has Mickey
mouse stuff. You know what I mean?
That's always creepy, isn't
it? You know that the,
the girl whose adult fully developed,
gone through puberty and actually has a
car payment and still acts like they're
fucking eight years old. Okay. And, uh,
I always thought that that was creepy.
You go and you go to hook up with them
and they have stuffed animals on their
baby mania. Wookiee pookie,
right? And there was just, you,
you felt like a fucking pedophile.
So listen to this.
Last week I did love line with uh,
um,
Psycho Mike and Dr drew.
I had a great time on the show and uh,
I was absolutely fucking blown away.
Bye.
Just the advice Dr drew gives and how
he gets right to the root of the problem
and then like his Hannibal Lecter ability,
remember the number of the fucking silence
of the lambs where he would just look
at somebody's shoes and could tell what
the fuck happened to them when they were
like 11.
Like doctor drew was doing that shit.
Like some girl called up, ah fuck
it. I might as well tell the story.
She calls up and like, Hey, you're on
Loveline, you know what's going on?
And then she's just saying,
yeah,
me really hates it.
Like you know,
like really hey,
hey.
And right off the bat he goes,
what happened to you when you were six?
And basically figured out that right
around that she didn't admit it.
She asked if she had ever been touched
here I'm laughing at fucking being
molested. I'm not laughing at the
show. I was just blown away. You know,
he asked him, he said no, she's like,
I like the tags, but my, my cousin,
I had to go to the trier and funding
and I asked him, I was like, how the
fuck did you do that? And he goes,
when I heard her, I heard a six
year old, the way she talked,
I heard a fucking six year
old. And sometimes when
that shit happens, you know,
it's so overwhelming that they just is
arrested development or something is what
he said.
So having seen that,
I mean maybe I'm now the, you know,
typical moron. That's what I do.
I stand next to a smart guy for 30
seconds and then try to rephrase what the
fuck he just said and try
to appear smart myself.
But now there's a whole new level
of being creeped out when you know,
you see girls like that and uh,
yeah,
that was always the vibe I felt like,
can you like, you know those, you go,
you go into their fucking bedroom
and it's like a little girl's room
and it's like, can you get that
fucking stuff off of your bed?
Like the whole thing is like
pink. I mean, I dunno if I,
if I'm just fucking,
you know,
just connecting dots now that
don't even fucking exist.
But now I'm looking back and all these
fucking, all these horrors that you see,
uh, uh, on those, the, that,
that dead fucking old guy to
playboy mansion who have those,
they walk around with that,
those stupid fucking high
heels with the Fuzzy Pink Shit.
The fur on it talking like they're,
they're little girls
does. Is that what that means? Ah, it's
just, it's, it's fucking beyond creepy.
So at this point,
because of that little moment on Loveline,
if I saw somebody and they had like a
bunch of Mickey Mouse Shit, I would,
I would first figure
out if, if I, I dunno,
like what's with the Batman thing?
Yeah. What's with that guy? Okay.
Has all this Batman stuff.
Did he get fucking diddled when he was
reading a comic book when he was nine?
So now he has this arrested development
that now he's actually fucking at work
any sitting in there doing this adult job,
but in his head,
just trying to block out the trauma that
happened in his head. He just says, yes,
Dan Nnn, nnn, nnn.
Just playing on a loop.
Non fucking Stop Batman.
You know, there's man
in there. Batman. Okay.
Bad. That's just fucking weird to
me. Do I have anything like that?
I don't. Okay. Oh, there goes that fucking
theory. All right. Plowing ahead. Um,
as to the hoarding,
his work area is ridiculous and
something of a tourist highlight.
And when anyone visits are, uh, are
off something of a tourist highlight.
When anyone visits our office,
we work in a, in a four man.
We work in four main areas and sets.
No one wants to sit with them.
He's taken the initiative to expand his
rubbish empire over the entire area.
The dude as a problem since our last
supervised visor tried to make an example
of him by banishing him to the wall,
to a work site with no desk and
just the locker. Lo and behold,
word got back to us that he started
a new nest of garbage by the lockers.
Why don't they just fire this
guy? Okay? I don't know. Whatever.
It just keeps going on and on with this
fucking guy and he's got damn trash.
You know what? This reminds you
guys have a haze. Anybody at work?
I used to work in this
warehouse and we were,
we were a bunch of fucking maniacs and
all day long, all we did was break balls.
Okay?
Uh,
I've told you this shit before because
we were basically mentally smart enough
to work in a warehouse by the time you
went third grade, you know what I mean?
Supposed to be 10 boxes according to the
packing list. One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
There you go. One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12. Sorry,
sesame street, flashback. Um,
okay.
So we used to fuck around all the time
and our manager had no control over us.
You know, we didn't respect him. We
knew he wasn't going to win fire.
We wasn't going to fire us.
He didn't have the goddamn heart.
And at the end of the day
we got a fucking job done.
So he decides that were the problem is,
is that we're all too fucking young.
There's a level of immaturity out there.
Cause we were all in our early twenties
that we, uh, that he should hire.
He hired this 38 year old guy.
MMM.
I actually remember his name,
but I'm not going to,
I don't name names on this shit. And uh,
Jesus Christ, that fucking guys almost 60,
he was like 38 and that was
22 fucking years ago. He's 60
what the fuck?
So anyways,
this guy drove a fucking Sky Blue
Chevy cavalier station wagon,
four door bare bones,
factory fucking rims.
The car was like three years old.
He had 8,000 miles on it,
all right?
And this guy was a Weirdo and
he had these fucking glasses,
these black frame glasses that nobody
wore in the eighties so we immediately
started calling him
woody. We'd be, hey woody,
how many boxes we get over there?
And this guy was just bizarre.
And he'd come home, why call me woody?
You are you trying to bring me down?
He kept saying,
you're trying to bring me down.
Then I already tell this fucking story.
This sounds oddly familiar to me.
So we would just fuck with them.
We would just be like, okay,
at four 31 today, everybody
just start going, what do
you, what do you, what do you,
what are you in? That's what
we would do. He would be
picking orders down in the,
in the warehouse area.
And we would all be picking orders
with them. And then out of nowhere
we would just start going, woody,
woody, woody, woody, woody,
top of our fucking lungs.
I know it's fucking am as sophomores,
but it would fit. And what? We wouldn't
say it to him, we would just fucking be,
it was really passive aggressive cause
he already talked to management about us
calling him woody. So it's
like, dude, we're not calling
you. Woody would just go on
woody, woody, woody, woody, woody,
look in your vicinity. So we do the
same thing and trying to bring me down.
You're trying to break me down.
So eventually we haze this guy so
much that he fucking quit, right?
He and his little Chevy cavalier
of fucking four doors, sky blue,
bare bone station wagon drove right out.
And the back of my head I was like,
you know what? I've got a bad feeling
that motherfuckers coming back.
It was about right around the time
when people first started going postal.
So it wasn't enough that that we
actually drove this guy out of work.
What are they fucking maniacs
I worked with somehow.
Got The guys home phone number and the
following week he still didn't have a job
and he picked up the
phone. He's like, hello.
And there was 10 of us standing
around the phone and we all go,
Ooh.
And I always pictured him slamming the
phone down and then looking up like that
dude in a clockwork work orange when he
realizes the dude who came and fucking
kick the shit out of him and
raped his wife came back. Um,
that's kind of an ugly story,
isn't it?
Yeah.
You know,
for as much as people sit there and they
talk about this cyber bullying and all
this type of shit and how
fucking horrible it is,
which it is obviously a,
you know,
I don't like how everybody tries
to act like they were a victim.
Well, I mean, weren't you a
little bit of both? Cause I,
I know I used to get bullied.
Jesus Christ walking up the street
looking like fucking that kid on the, uh,
the family Griffith with the fuck is that?
Hello? Andy Griffith? How did I
come up with the family Griffith?
Ah, my fucking brain is
mush. Um, yeah, people,
you immediately came walking up
the street and my fucking mind,
my hair was orange when I was growing up.
I think I didn't get the shit kicked
out of me, you know, but then, you know,
I got a little bit bigger.
I've got a couple more freckles.
I got got some more confidence and I
just started picking on kids who were a
younger than I was.
So now whenever I see
those God damn stories,
mmm. I, I just, I don't know. I,
I see both sides of it.
I just see like, yeah,
you shouldn't have fucking done that.
But I don't judge the bully
because I did shit like that. No,
you guys didn't do shit like that.
Yeah. Go Fuck Yourself. All right.
Why don't you guys, do you know what?
That's the theme of this whole podcast.
Every can go fuck themselves. I can
just put me off in such a goddamn movie.
You might want to make that a
priority. Okay. Um, anyways,
what do I got coming up this week?
Let's hype my gigs. Shall We?
Let's try to get something
positive going here. God. No,
it was already have to go make up with
fucking Nia. I get it. I get that.
It's a podcast, but you
have to be mean. Okay. Um,
oh by the way, let's talk about
something podcast, uh, podcast podcasts,
something positive. Um, I let it go.
DVD was the number one fucking downloaded
comedy album on iTunes this week,
so I want to thank all you guys for
that. Um, I really appreciate it.
Keep buying it.
Keep downloading the son of a bitch.
If you go to bill bird.com I've got a
link right there. You Click right on.
It takes you right to amazon.com
once again, I told you, man,
it makes a tremendous fucking gifts for
some of you. Don't give a shit about,
watch this.
I'm going to click on this shit right now.
They're probably selling it for fucking
three bucks at this point. What is it?
Down to 10 99 you cheap cuts 10 99.
Come on, come on. You fuckers
already gave you the Oh,
Jesus pod. Goddamn ringtone. I made
300 bucks off debt. You cheap fucks.
99 cents. That's it. 300
bucks. You motherfucker.
What are you guys saving up for a
happy meal? You tight fucks. Uh,
you know, I always seem to
be selling something that
is just completely obsolete.
I sold a ringtone back when people now
had the technology to make their own
ringtone.
And now I'm selling a DVD.
Next month I'm going to be
selling in brand new VCR.
Everybody now seriously,
please go out and buy it because
this is the big thing about that.
Just download the fucker.
Cause I want to tell you,
even if you saw it on comedy central,
you have not seen my standup special yet.
You haven't seen it. I ain't going. Hey,
let me call you right
back in five minutes. Um,
you have not seen when, when I say I'm
going to call you back in five minutes,
that means in about an hour and
a half, unless I forget. Um,
you haven't seen my specialty
yet because it was edited.
They took out two huge chunks of
material. Uh, this is my, I'm telling you,
this is my best work so far and I really
want you to fucking see it and then buy
tickets to my show so I can buy a big
goddamn house and have a pool inside and
outside and then just sit there and still
be sad and depressed and realize that
I need to work on myself. That's the
goal. People, that is definitely the goal.
So let's hype the gigs I got this week
are coming up in the next week. Um,
I'm going to be at the Wilbur Theater
in Boston, Massachusetts October 20th.
And all proceeds after they're done
taxing us and a pain for the theater are
going to go, uh, to my brother's
campaign who's running for state senate.
Uh, just to let you know. All right,
I've got to put that out there legally.
That's what you're going there.
That's what you're supporting.
If you don't support his message,
please do not go.
I'm not trying to trick anybody. This
is all on the up and up. All right?
And then after that, I'm going
to be an, um, October 22nd.
And we at the pantageous
theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota on the 23rd I'm going to be
at the Vic Theater in Chicago, Illinois.
Um,
the following week,
I have one night only at the
funny bone in Saint Louis,
Missouri on October 30th one night,
only October 30th at the
funny bone in Saint Louis.
And I'm hanging around an extra day
and I'm going to go to the rams.
How about those fucking lions? Huh?
I stayed away from him this week.
Well that's what the fuck I was going to
talk about. You know, I did. I did my, uh,
pick my three teams this week again.
All right.
You want to know who the fuck I had?
See if I got it here.
I had Atlanta first
Cleveland given three points.
It's like there's no way the browns are
going to win two weeks in a row and fuck
that man.
Genie,
that rat cunt who sat in the goddamned
getaway car during the bank robbery and
then Brad and out the guys in the
bank, that fucking rat bastard. So, uh,
I took Atlanta. I won that game.
Then I had to four o'clock games.
I had the Tennessee titans getting
seven points versus the cowboys.
Right? My Buddy Paul Versey
says, he's told me, he goes,
all Vince young does is win. And I dunno,
Tony Romo just doesn't do it for me.
He just fails at a very,
very high level,
throws for 300 5,400 yards
and they still somehow lose.
Although another one of my buddies
is telling me it's the play calling,
it's not his fault,
but I just felt like a seven
points was a lot of fucking points.
So now I'm 2.0 and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
I got to God Damn San Diego
charges getting six points first.
The Oakland Raiders,
I might go three now and actually
start gambling for fucking real.
If I can pick them like this.
This is ridiculous.
So San Diego has the fucking ball that
down by one point and they're run like
Oakland's 10 yard line and
I'm just sitting there.
I already got my arms in the air.
I'm like, worst case scenario,
they kick a field goal,
they miss it.
They're only down by one in Oakland
is just going to run out the clock.
I'm going to win this. I'm getting
six points. Either fucking way.
San Diego kicks the Goddamn Ball.
I'm going to win by eight.
They missed the field goal.
They run it out.
I'll still clear my bed by five points.
And this is why I don't gamble.
Fucking Philip Rivers goes back to pass,
brings his arm back.
Some defensive events slaps the fucking
ball out of his hand. It's a fumble.
Somebody from the Raiders picks the ball
up and runs like fucking 90 yards for a
touchdown.
And I ended up losing the God damn bet.
And I'm gonna tell you right now people
that right there is why I don't gamble.
That's why I don't gamble.
So well let me see if I would
have one even if I teased it.
Cause if you tease it on three teen
tease, don't you get like nine points? Um,
cause I would've wanted my
first week and I still think,
I think I would have won.
Right. Hang on one second.
So they ended up losing by eight points.
Yeah,
I would've won if I teased it.
I still would have fucking one one night.
Don't you get nine points on a three t
teas? I should have fucking done that man.
I would have won two out of three weeks.
All right.
I'm going to start putting my
picks up on the, uh, the MLM,
podcast.com so you guys can follow along.
I might even ask Versie if we'll,
we'll put both of ours up
and you can watch right now.
We're both five and four for the year.
Uh,
so I went to in one this God damn week.
And uh,
as far as the Monday night game tonight,
who do you like?
Who Do you like the jets or the Vikings?
I got to go with the jets.
I just think,
you know Brett Farve still trying
to tuck his God damn unit away.
But I think Randy Moss,
I dunno,
I dunno. Is Reavis back, is
he back from Reavis island?
Fucking fag.
Randy beat me.
Is he gonna grab for his fucking hamstring
again when fucking Randy beats him
again over the top when he has
no help when he's one on one.
That was my favorite player of
the year watching Randy Moss.
Just skipping down the sandy
beaches of fucking Reavis island.
That insecure bastard who would ever
come up with that could, you could,
we could, when you come
to Reavis island, there's,
there's no way to get off
unless you have a boat. Oh,
okay. They are Reavis. Um, anyways,
I think that that's the podcast
for this week. Please. Um,
if you're in the Boston area
and you want to come down, uh,
it helps support my brother's campaign.
That's a big thing.
This is the last second
date that we're adding.
So we're trying to hope we can get as
many people as we humanly possibly can.
Um,
get down to the theater.
And for those of you living in Chicago,
there's about 50 tickets left
and same thing in Minneapolis.
So I want to thank everybody ahead of
time for the unbelievable fucking support.
Uh,
isn't actually hilarious.
I'm playing a theater in Minneapolis next
week and I'm not picking them against
the jets. Um, whatever.
I just want to thank all you guys for
supporting me and my comedy and a,
I wanna thank the Penn state
Nittany lions for losing this week,
getting their fucking asses kicked because
I'm going to be at the Columbus funny
bone and obviously Columbus,
Ohio on 11th,
November 12th through the 14th and all
the Ohio state buckeyes a playing Penn
state and it's to be announced
but with the two losses,
I think it will be in the afternoon.
I think it's official at this point that
they won't be contending for anything.
And uh, I was really nervous at that
game was going to be at eight o'clock,
which would mean that a,
I don't get to go to the game and B,
no one will be at my show because
they'll all be out there going,
oh h Oh motherfucker.
Um,
and that's it. How about my Boston
Bruins? Huh? You liked that shit.
You like that anybody can just fly to
fucking Saint Louis or Dallas and get
their first loss of the year.
It takes a real team to fly all the way
over to Prague to get your fucking ass
is kicked to start the
year off. Right. Um,
can you explain to me why
they keep doing fucking, uh,
American sports over there in,
in Europe? Like they give a shit,
like they're going to start
buying it up like our genes,
like every year the NFL does that fucking
God damn game and Wembley Stadium.
Yeah. I don't, I don't, I
guess it sells out. I Dunno.
But if you go over there, they
don't give a fuck. They were debt.
They were into soccer or their version
of football. Absolutely fucking, I dunno.
Oh, Jesus. You know what?
This is the greatest way to end this
fucking podcast right now with just like,
uh, I came in, they, you know
what this, this, this podcast
is like march, you know,
in with the, in, in like a lion out like
a lamb. I'm going out like a lamb here.
All right. That's it. Everybody
have a great God damn week.
I hope to see you. Uh,
next Wednesday, October 20th at the
Wilbur Theater in Boston, Massachusetts.
Helped my brother out. Um, and
that's it. God bless all. Yeah,
I'll talk to you next week.
Okay.